yes I have a bit of a cold if you can't
tell but I come here to do the reviews
the objective reviews that you all know
I do and if I sound like beetlejuice and
you hate it it's a right you know why I
didn't want to hang out with you
deadbeats anyway thank you kidding I
love you guys run all night so run all
nights newest Liam Neeson old dude
kickin ass move it Liam Neeson's his old
school ex hitman Ed Harris is pretty
much the mobster running everything the
two were childhood friends and Ed Harris
his sons following in his dad's
footsteps but he's like a screw-up and
Liam Neeson's son wants nothing to do
with that life whatsoever just wants to
be an upstanding individual he wants to
help kids at Harris his son tries to
kill Liam Neeson son Liam Neeson's like
I've a particular set of skills
bang shoot some kills them after that
Eddie Harris is like I'm coming after
your son leave me sons like why do
people mess with my family you know that
by now don't mess with Liam Neeson's
family I was surprised at how much I
enjoyed this movie though I mean it
would have been so easy just give Liam
Neeson know they're gonna be like hey
make another shitty taken movie taking
one was great it was a fun movie the
other ones not so much this will Liam
Neeson's hitting kind of a stride you
like oh you have story you have heart
like his son wants nothing to do with
them but his son needs him to live cuz I
mean mobsters are coming after you you
need your dad to be Liam Neeson
otherwise you're just kind of screwed
the cops are all crooked they can't turn
to anybody it was raw - it wasn't like
the clean taking kills was all bad bam
bam done like he shoots someone they
just look at their dad no this is like
the dirty cat this is like sprayed for
30 seconds in there you're like oh he
died the movies always constantly going
it's one of those things where I mean a
lot of irons are in the fire at some
point in this movie the cops are coming
after them they're going after this K
the mobs going after them Liam Neeson's
going after ed Harris top it all off you
have Boba Fett in the movie now kind of
looks like it's like black both fat
people if it's black we don't know we
don't know what he looks like cuz the
prickles don't count maybe that's what I
could do Bubba feds voice now he's no
good like original trilogy Boba Fett I
have two thoughts about this guy one I
wanted to see more of him he's just kind
of thrown in the movie and he's just
thorn in everyone's side he's a hitman
who's in mode he's gonna get the job
done but you're like what's your story
dude so you want to know more about the
guy on the other hand you're like did
you come from the future because you
guys like this night-vision Google glass
where you're like does that tech exhibit
this take place you don't know but you
welcome him because he's just fun
elements like we have a movie like this
you need the cool hit man
guys I feel really bad I really do
because I'm gonna cut this [ __ ] short
because my voice is actually going away
and there's an there are more videos I
want to do after the weekend for nothing
else I need to save my voice for next
weekend but you get the gist of it by
now
in the end run all night was a fun movie
it was good it was taken with a little
more heart and substance than take it's
not as good as taken but it has more
depth than taken I like Liam Neeson I
liked his relationship with his son I
liked Ed Harris
I liked everyone in the movie movie gets
a little convoluted at times and I think
it's just that much it's like that much
too long but in the end I will say one
all night is definitely a good time no
alcohol required
alright guys in the last whispers of my
voice run all night have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see
[Music]